heute ist das nicht ein schöner tag
heute ich freue mich auch für neue
aufnahme holt punkt der ist icq ich habe
wieder richtig viele bilder
herausgesucht von wirklich spannenden
leuten die gute chancen haben deswegen
geht direkt auf die seite
da freue ich mich auf diese aufgabe
8.2 okay das ist für einen seite mehr an
wartet vielleicht einfach https okay ich
hab's ja aber ich habe hier oben
angegeben wie ich damals geöffnet http s
[Musik]
er hat es sich wirklich die seite runter
genommen ihr verdammten nutzen söhne
[Musik]
dieser das offline
die seite ist auf land leute kommt schon
mal ohne https mehr an tricks
interessiert keine ausgemacht wo ist
meine website hörte dass es kalt sich
der ernst sein es kann nicht ihr ernst
sein machine learning mit anlauf was
soll jetzt heute für video machen leute
ohne scheiß das gibt setze mich hin will
einfach aufnehmen und es gibt einfach
die website nicht mehr welches apa/red
würde ich sagen wollt ihr mich hoch
wartet er wollte mich hoch ybrig
hochnehmen ghana und wirtsleute ich ein
gradmesser zeitdruck ich habe in meinem
fall wenn man verabredete dann geht
diese seiten ich kack ab what the [ __ ]
[Musik]
dieses kapitels war dort lange nicht
gekommen
es sollte nicht so enden ich habe noch
so große träume noch so viele youtuber
vor mir die ich noch gerne auf der seite
analysieren wollte so viele videos die
ich noch hätte machen kann alles wenn
ihr irgendwie de ab die wir trotzdem
weiter auf diese videos machen können
dann schreib dir und gerne in die
kommentare ich denke mir dieses heutige
video war eine kleine verwirrung für
euch aber glaubt mir was für eine
verwirrung war das für mich ich gehe auf
diese seite und die wollen mich hoch
ich wollte mich ja leute das heutige
video war glaube ich bisschen verwirrend
für beide seiten die vor und die hinter
der kamera ich werde versuchen dafür
eine lösung zu finden helfen dabei gerne
mit wie gesagt schreiben die kommentare
wenn eine idee haben wir das machen kann
die tränen kamen echt gut oder ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass ich auf kommando
heulen kann